it won't work yeah because white king is  running out wait what happens on Rook F7  our Rook H2 is checkmate sorry just  Checkmate yeah and knocking King moves  look F1 check and we just move the the  king too easily  just to highlight that we can't take it  because then it's terminate  the enhance even puts the King on E2  just to make sure that he he just  continues then you just need to run out  with the king so that you avoid any kind  of stand Matrix  just amazing stuff all right so King E2  played and now Rook H2 is a threat  you're up a piece with no stalemate it  looks like  this might be game mobile and also now  you can go King D3 and anyway give up uh  your rook and Bishop for the H2 pawn and  win the King Pawn end game  yeah wow I mean okay so basically stuff  then uh does not make it he lost the  last two games